[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign he made the most of it there
drilling the go ahead triple
two quasars two of the best in the
business and what they do pressure one
pressure
the footwork special mr duran i've been
there many times i don't know what
pressure is
my game raises when it's on the line
[Applause]
[Music]
on the switch now draws the double gives
it up den for three and it goes down
back-to-back game winners by spencer
denwinnie he did it sunday in boston he
does it tonight in brooklyn at the gun
113
111
[Applause]
here in brooklyn where he spent five
years as a member of the nets playing in
just his 12th game as a maverick coming
over at the deadline
and the mavs remain
one of the hottest teams in basketball
you see that they wanted somebody else
to beat you
he's calling for the screen from cleva
he knows a double team is going to come
there's a switch he usually busts this
out kevin's trapping the challenge
by goron
but the shot making he had missed his
first three threes and he's had monster
threes in this second half
unbelievable he finishes with 22-15
in the fourth quarter including the
game-winning three
and the mavs have now an eight of nine
five in a row on the road and they are
17 games above 500 and spencer's
standing by with cassidy